In this lecture, we'll discuss
the idea of using visualization
to better understand data
and to provide insights
on the problem we're addressing.
Why visualization?
People often say that a picture
is like a thousand words.
In the same spirit, John
Tukey, a major statistician
at Princeton, wrote that
"the picture-examining eye
is the best finder we have
of the wholly unanticipated."
Visualizing data allows us
to discern relationships,
structures, distributions,
outliers, patterns, behaviors,
dependencies, and outcomes.
Visualization is further useful
for initial data exploration,
for interpreting models, and
for communicating results
effectively.
Let us give some examples
of different modes
of visualization that
illustrate these points.
The figure shows
the miles per gallon
of a car as a function
of the car's weight.
The figure clearly illustrates
that as the weight of the car
increases, the miles
per gallon decrease.
The same graph, but now
colors of the points
signify the number of cylinders
in the car: four for red,
six for green,
and eight in blue.
On the same data, we now
plot a regression line
that captures the intuition
that as the weight of the car
increases, the miles
per gallon decrease.
In this plot, we'll
visualize burglaries
in the city of Houston by
combining data and geographical
location in a map.
This plot illustrates,
using a heat map,
the usage of rented bicycles
from the Hubway company.
The horizontal axis is
the hour of the day,
and the vertical axis the day
of the week, starting on Sunday.
The heat map shows that
the usage increases
during the morning and night
rush hours on weekdays.
The next plot helps us
visualize histograms
of different categories
using the Hubway data.
This plot shows US
unemployment by state.
The lighter colors corresponding
to smaller unemployment,
and the darker
colors corresponding
to larger unemployment rates.
The plan this week is to create
all of these visualizations.
We'll see how visualizations
can be used to better understand
data, communicate
information more effectively,
show the results of
analytical models.
In the next video, we'll discuss
the World Health Organization,
and how they use
visualizations effectively.